OK.
Let's start today with a story about the failings
of most Democrats in the United States, elected
Democrats now.
I'm still on the left.
The Democratic Party is a center left party.
I'm a progressive.
This is a left wing channel.
We criticize the right all the time today.
I'm going to criticize Democrats on their
response to the police protest.
So let me set the stage for you.
Republicans, of course, have completely and
utterly failed in their response to the protests,
with the exception of, for example, like Republican
Senator Mitt Romney, who showed up and marched
with protesters and said Black Lives Matter,
which was mostly mostly just a political show,
although I think it's an important action
and an important political show, but it's
essentially a political show.
Republicans have refused to admit that there
are systemic problems that need to be dealt
with.
Kaley McEnany did this yesterday during her
press briefing.
Instead, they focus on phrases like sometimes
there will be instances of racism or bad apples.
But meanwhile, they often support using even
more force against protesters who are protesting
against police brutality.
So the right is off the deep end.
I've also criticized some of the activists
on the left who I believe are taking the wrong
approach, for example, with defund or abolish
the police.
I already explained yesterday in detail why
I think that's the wrong approach.
But today, the point is I want to focus on
the failure, the abject failure of the Democratic
Party leadership itself.
This was a beautiful opportunity for the Democratic
Party to dramatically distinguish itself from
the Republican Party.
I often talk about on many issues, Democrats
and Republicans are very different.
Sometimes they're very similar.
Here was an opportunity for Democrats to put
together a blistering systemic critique of
how we got to where we are with the protests
as an outlet for much of what is going wrong
in our country.
If you listen or watch, listen to or watch
the clip from last Monday's show, I broke
down how this is not just about police brutality.
You need to look at this more systemically.
What we're seeing is not just about racism.
It's not just about capitalism.
It's not just about health care or culture.
It's all of these things together.
And you need a wide ranging systemic critique
to appreciate everything that has gotten us
to where we are today.
And bias in policing is a big part of that,
Democrats overall.
And by this, I mean elected Democrats, particularly
House leadership and Democrats in the Senate
first really did nothing.
Eventually, they said, yeah, we support protests
against police brutality.
They participated in a bunch of photo ops,
which mean meaningful in a sense, but doesn't
really create a systemic critique of what's
going on.
And it's great that Nancy Pelosi joined protesters
and talked to people.
It's important that Elizabeth Warren joined
a protest.
It's great that Democratic presidential candidate
Joe Biden went and spoke to protesters.
But this would have been a perfect opportunity
for a big systemic critique that combines
everything from our economic system.
Problem with wages, wealth inequality, are
voting system.
So many other components.
This was the opportunity to change the narrative
or create a narrative.
It could have been like the Occupy Wall Street
moment where income inequality and wealth
inequality went mainstream.
You had Republicans and Democrats disagreeing
about what should be done about it.
But Occupy Wall Street mainstreamed the topic
of wealth and income inequality.
Instead, what we got from most Democrats is
this mild support of protesters, cautious,
of course, never to support the tactics that
were used and very quick to focus on how they
don't agree with many of the tactics, which
is fine.
But they're missing the real big opportunity
in conjunction with some totally farcical,
performative events like the video that we're
showing our radio or our video audience right
now of House and Senate Democrats kneeling
for eight minutes and 46 seconds in honor
of George Floyd.
It is totally performative.
I'd be fine with it if it came with a big
systemic critique.
And we've been sounding the alarm for years
about that sort of necessary systemic critique
because there are so many different systems
that need to change now.
In addition to Democrats not leaving a valid
systemic criticism in terms of the systems
that got us where we are and need to be changed.
There also haven't been any real big comments
from establishment Democrats about the civil
liberties totalitarianism.
Argument Republicans have been going hard,
demanding the military come in, tougher policing,
all of this stuff.
And Democrats have sort of meekly opposed
the tactics, said we were not in in agreement
with the military coming in, but they've not
really gone after, hey, not only is sending
the military in wrong.
But Republicans have spent years criminalizing
civil disobedience, criminalizing poverty,
criminalizing journalism, much like with the
ag gag laws, which now can be tied into the
protests as we see some journalists just straight
up beaten, hit with shields and batons and
nightsticks.
There is a much bigger story here that the
country is primed for right now, which Democrats
could be taking advantage of.
And they have not talking about how so much
about protesters rights is inextricably linked
to our surveillance state, warrantless wiretapping,
NSA surveillance, sting ray devices.
My point here is that there is so much that
is bigger than we like the protesters and
Trump shouldn't send in the military and police
brutality is bad.
Now, why aren't Democrats doing it?
There's a couple of perspectives.
One explanation would be Democrats aren't
doing it because the Democratic Party is very
centrist and they don't really believe in
all that stuff.
That's true.
But to some degree, definitely it is not true
about all Democrats.
There are many Democrats who are keeping quiet
for political expediency, for a calculation
that it's better for their reelection if they
don't talk about that stuff in this context.
Maybe they're making the right calculation
for their reelection.
Maybe they're not.
But this is a huge missed opportunity.
And this is one of the areas where the scope
of debate has been narrowed dramatically,
where there should be a big systemic critique
from Democrats here.
And instead, we are getting the military shouldn't
come in.
Police brutality is a problem.
And missing so much of what could really change
the dialog in this country.
This is a failure, a moral failure by Democrats,
whether it's a strategic failure.
Maybe it's not.
I mean, maybe maybe they're making the right
strategic calculation in terms of their reelections.
But the moral failure is impossible to ignore.